the only do you ever watch a Kirby
enthusiasm I love Caribbean it's my
favorite show ever one of my favorite
shows like the only thing I relate to
Country Club [ __ ] is everything that him
and Jeff oh bro because they're always
talking about that episode with the swan
oh just there's a million episodes
man if I get like Larry David's age I'm
a I'ma join me at Country Club for sure
I'm gonna get wrapped up in a bunch of
old [ __ ] politics with these old
[ __ ] people yeah
it just looks great on this shirt I
can't wait to the next season oh the
last season was amazing when he was
[ __ ] that annoying uh politician lady
bro yeah that was oh my God would you
where would you rank like a give me your
top five like sitcoms like or comedies I
can't I'm just terrible at the top five
things just give me five of your
favorites no no we're not talking about
dramas we're not talking about the
breaking bads of the world or The
Sopranos I'm talking about just funny
shows
funny shows man
um my God I can't do this with you
I seriously can't man because I tell you
this like after I watch curb that made
me go back and watch Seinfeld yeah I was
I so I watched Seinfeld first I never I
didn't get it I couldn't understand I
was younger obviously but I mean I never
understood it until I saw a curve my
wife curve and then I wouldn't watch
Seinfeld it's [ __ ] brilliant yeah uh
then I watched for some like for some
reason I watched [ __ ] Frasier I love
Frazier Fraser solid Fraser is funny as
[ __ ] which was a spin-off of Cheers yep
and then like you know I'm just on I've
been on that like I just been on the
like watching the old joints that you
know uh
you know The Sopranos man Sopranos is a
Ray Donovan oh Ray Donovan is that I
just I can't do that I can't do the face
hey but not a lot of people [ __ ] with
Ray Donovan yeah that's Matt looks like
Ray Donovan by the way I think that's
just I think I think it might be racist
yeah
you just told me all white people look
the same and and no no I didn't I'm
looking at that right
Ray Donovan was crazy no but Sopranos
what about did you [ __ ] with the wire of
course the wires I re-watched them
during the pandemic for the first time
in like 10 years and I was like it's the
goat to me yeah the wire is crazy I got
the wire Breaking Bad Sopranos those are
my three yeah on the funny [ __ ] though
it's like Curb Your Enthusiasm and then
just everything else yeah The Boondocks
I like I like like new girl oh I mean
you know The Boondocks obviously yeah uh
shout out to my brother new girl shout
out to my brother doe burger man you
know Long Live dough Burger you know I
just lost him we were literally we're
literally Huey and Riley from The
Boondocks wow so you know I had to
mention I had to say that since you said
that I like new girl on uh Netflix new
girl's good new girl that's funny as
hell uh [ __ ] um do you ever watch F
is for family the Bill Burr [ __ ]
he's got to see the cartoon right that
was pretty funny uh Happy Endings yeah
do you watch any stand-up [ __ ] yeah are
you like who's like like what's I want
to see JB Smoove so bad live he's so
funny he's [ __ ] hilarious man uh if
you think about like his character it's
like so iconic on TV oh bro yeah bro
that whole when they had that [ __ ]
episode where he was like fixing [ __ ]
for people he was like the handyman but
he really didn't know what the [ __ ] he
was doing by the end of the episode
everything breaks that he fixed yeah
classic [ __ ]